it's the biggest prison in the Americas
and will be home to 40 000 inmates
including some of the most violent
people on the continent
was given a special tour of the jail at
tekalua built in just seven months he
was shown the seven security rings from
the watchtowers and electric fences to
the solid steel isolation cells
it's important to remember that the
people that will be held here the
terrorists who will be here are the
highest ranking members of The Gangs the
historic leaders El Salvador has a gang
problem in March last year the
government declared the state of
emergency to fight it previous efforts
to break the gangs in El Salvador's
overcrowded jails haven't worked even
with 24-hour lockdowns stripping and
humiliating inmates even putting rival
gangs into overcrowded sales together
they were still able to run their
operations on the outside and smuggle in
phones computers guns even prostitutes
then last year police and army arrested
more than 62 000 suspected gang members
and those that work with them but the
Crackdown has led human right
organizations to complain innocent
people are being scooped up civil rights
are being ignored but Ordinary People
tired of gang violence say they're happy
with the changes it's bringing
I like them because at least now we feel
safe before we always thought something
could happen to us before we trusted no
one now we feel safer
with sixty thousand people already in
jail El Salvador has two percent of its
adult population Behind Bars the highest
incarceration rate in the world
the prison will start accepting new
inmates in the coming days they will be
guarded by around 600 troops and 250
police officers it will say the
authorities be impossible to escape
Alan Fisher Al Jazeera